[Music]
Design Thinking is a process for
developing multiple ideas with a
particular user in mind and and new ways
to solve problems based on the creative
design process it is there is nothing
inherent in design thinking that has
benefit or no benefit to society social
design is looking at ways to affect
entire communities or organizations and
social design inevitably has a moonshot
objective you know a North Star that
defines a vision that's an ultimate
condition that people want to create
typically the way we solve problems and
the kind of problem-solving that humans
are really good at are technical
problems you know we know how to make
the next app we know how to make a
driverless car or whatever it is right
when it's very concretely defined and
it's linear we excel at that the thing
that we have not succeeded at is solving
the big complicated social problems we
have social design is an approach that
works at a systems level that brings
cross-disciplinary teams together so
that everyone who has a hand or who has
responsibility for making something
happen is is a participant from the
beginning and the sequential steps of
research and engineering and iteration
and designing are collapsed and in the
social design process we talked about
making to learn and so as a part of
research there are prototypes developed
at every stage there is a kind of
testing that goes on at every stage with
the people that are intended to use
it and that feedback becomes information
for the next step so instead of
following a long strategic plan people
are in real time observing the reaction
to what's happening and adapting the the
whatever they're developing as it
happens we find that the biggest changes
happen in the people who participate in
it and so in developing this capacity
for reframing problems and for
developing ideas and for prototyping and
for navigating ambiguity that capacity
resides in people and they take it on to
other things and it changes cultures
jeffrey Brown who is a remarkable grocer
his he's a fourth-generation grocer and
he's built something like a six hundred
million dollar grocery store empire in
Philadelphia but he sells high-quality
suburban suburban quality food like you
know super supermarkets in food deserts
which means in the poorest neighborhoods
of Philadelphia and he's able to do that
essentially because his vision is not to
have a grocery store empire his vision
is to use his business to address issues
of poverty and poor health in these
vulnerable neighborhoods and that's one
of the hallmarks of anyone who is a a
brilliant social designer is that it
begins with an ultimate vision not I
want to have a successful business not
you know I want to launch a website it's
the the real understanding of a purpose
that creates energy and that aligns
everyone around the same goal and that
provides enough of a you know a magnet
towards this North Star that people can
pivot as necessary an experiment as
necessary in how to get there Jeffrey
Brown is constantly experimenting with
how to accomplish what he wants to
accomplish he experiments with whether
he calls it flame broiled chicken will
be as popular as fried chicken because
it's healthier for people he experiments
with well if I put the skill milk where
the whole milk usually is will people
automatically grab that for fewer
calories he experiments teaching people
how to cook he experiments giving
classes or tours of the store helping
people read food labels he experimented
with one of the one of his customers
because Jeffrey's always talking to the
people in the neighborhoods he comes to
them and tells them what he's thinking
about and and gets their advice and one
woman said you know a lot of people in
these neighborhoods don't have jobs
because they've been in prison and as
long as they don't have jobs they won't
be able to shop in your store why don't
you do something about that and so
Jeffrey Brown founded a nonprofit called
uplift that trains people who have been
in prison and guarantees them a job in a
store so a third of his workforce is now
people who have been as they say touched
by the justice system
[Music]